♪ ♪ ♪
la vaccination permettrait
d'éliminer le virus de la COVID-
19, un peu comme on l'a fait
avec la variole, ou du moinsntes
le cas de la rougeole.
Mais avec l'arrivée fulgurante
d'Omicron, qui déjoue notre dur,
ces espoirs se sont évaporés
Le consensus scientifique
se consolide. Le virus est lpou,
il deviendra endémique.
Il sera alors le cinquième
coronavirus à l'être, auxdes qus
qui causent les rhumes communs.
La pandémie se terminera alors
non pas par une éradication du
virus, mais par une transitioné,
quand la maladie deviendra
moins mortelle, plus prévisible,
comparable aux grippes
suggèrent que cette transition
survenir dans la
prochaine année.
déterminer le passage entre
pandémique et
la phase endémique du virus?
Il n'existe pas de critère
de définition universelle.
Selon CDC américain, un virus
est dit endémique lorsqu'il est
dans une population avec
un taux d'infection relativement
prévisible et une circulation
Pour y parvenir, la maladie doit
atteindre une forme d'équilibre
avec notre immunité collective.
Cela implique que près de
la total
ait une forme d'immunité acquise
par la v ou par une
infection. Cette immunité serait
alors su
des pics de propagation,
uffisante uffisante uffisante ua
stopper, car cette protectionser
la perte d'immunité causée
le temps ou par les mutationsdut
au virus de continuer à
Une situation bien différente
de la situation actuelle, diueùs
sont encore sans immunité,
permettant encore des flambées
de la propagation, plongeanton é
dans la tempête.
♪ ♪ ♪
Dans le dernier siècle,
nous avons vu plusieurstte
transition.
La grippe espagnole de 1918,
après trois vagues mortelles,ipe
saisonnière endémique
encore avec nous aujourd'hui.
Il y a eu aussi le sidaippe por.
Ce sont des maladies avec
lesquelles nous avons appris à
vivre, dont nous savons évaluess
nous savons protéger
les plus vulnérables.
Pour les gouvernements,ître ques
deviendra endémiqu
cesser de penser qu'il y aura
une date de fin. Cpréparer à uns
une gestion d'une a
COVID. De plus en plus de pays
parle d'une transition prochaine
en particulier depuis l'arrivée
du variant Omicron, dont le taux
d'hospitalisation semble
précédents et qui fait miroiter
une situation un jour plus
gérable.Il affecte à grande vite
la popul
son immunisation.
Aussi, des décès de la COVID étq
à dix feur à celeur à celeur à e
l'influenza. Mais avec
la vacci
des traitements antiviraux,
les scientifiques espèrent qu'on
pourrait réduire les risques
décès de plus de 90 % par
rapport à 2020, ce qui pourrait
abaisser ce risque à moins
de 0,1 %, un niveau similaire
à celui de la grippe.
♪ ♪ ♪
L'arrivée de l'endémie
gne et
le Royaume-Uni ont suggéré
passer prochainement
estion pluestion pluestion pluee
à une maladie endémique,
de celle de la grippe.
Aux Etagroupe de travail sur ln
de la COsident Bidsident Bidsidn
ont publié la semaine dernière
dans lesquels ils réclament la
plan national
pour mener cette transition.
Mais mer
à ces annonces, l'OMS mettait en
garde co
rapide.
Aussi, le chemin vers
la phase
pas forcément direct ou facile.
Rien n'edes prochains mois, l'ée
ts échappats échappats échappatt
à notre immunité, plus
des pics de mortalité.
Nous ne savons pas, à terme
de quoi aura l'air la COVID
endémique, sa sévéé,
le rythme auquel i
aux vaccins. Certains spéculent
qu'elle pourrait unigne que les
coronavirus qui ca
rhume. Mais elle pourrait aussi
continuer à peserèmes de santé,a
grippe s
depuis longtemps et qui,
pourtantplus impplus impplus imé
dans les
On s'attend donc en 2022 à ce
plus en plus de place. Comment ?
Comment se préparer à cohabiter
Comment passer de l'étate d'un e
à la gestion d'un virus